hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is language death normally
on this channel when I talk about a
language it's usually a living language
a language that's still spoken by native
speakers today and continues to grow and
evolve but there are also dead languages
and extinct languages languages are
considered dead when they simply have no
more native speakers even though they
may continue to be used in some way
Latin is dead for example but it
continues to be used for religious
purposes and for some administrative
purposes in the Vatican some people can
speak it but not naturally like a native
language and it's not passed down as a
native language another example is
Hebrew which was a dead language before
its revival in the form of modern Hebrew
nobody spoke it natively for a long time
but it continued to be used for
religious purposes and as a written
literary language in contrast languages
are considered extinct when no living
person can speak them for example if the
last remaining speaker of a Native
American language dies and nobody has
learned it as a second language then
that language becomes extinct
likewise ancient languages like Sumerian
are extinct some people might be able to
read ancient texts in that language but
nobody really uses it today languages
become either dead or extinct as a
result of language death types of
language death languages don't always
die in the same way there are various
types of language death the most common
way that languages disappear is through
gradual language death this normally
happens when speakers of one language
come into contact with a language of
higher prestige the language of a
dominant more powerful group of people
that community may remain bilingual for
quite a long time but with each
successive generation fewer young people
speak their traditional language and
with lower levels of proficiency as they
opt to use the prestige language instead
until one day their communities
traditional language is no longer spoken
an example of this is Cornish which
ceased to be spoken by the late 19th
century as a result of the growing
influence of English and also as a
result of the perception of Cornish as a
lower class language even amongst its
own speakers at the time but Cornish is
actually not extinct
because there are revitalization efforts
to encourage people to continue to use
that language next bottom-to-top
language death in bottom-to-top language
death a language ceases to be used as a
native spoken language but continues to
be used in certain contexts normally in
a formal religious context or ceremonial
context or perhaps for literary purposes
in gradual language death the language
normally disappears first in more formal
contexts as its replaced by the prestige
language but it continues to be spoken
in more casual contexts for a longer
time in bottom-to-top language death on
the other hand the language dies out at
the bottom in other words in casual
context but it continues to be used in
more formal contexts an example of this
is Latin which is basically no longer
used outside of religious or ceremonial
contexts or perhaps literary contexts
next southern language death southern
language death occurs when all or almost
all the speakers of a language suddenly
die as a result of a disaster or
violence an example of this took place
in the 1830s in Tasmania when virtually
all of the islands native inhabitants
were wiped out by European colonists
during the black war next radical
language death similar to southern
language death radical language death
normally happens very rapidly and
normally happens as a result of
political repression or under threat of
violence the difference is that the
languages speakers are not wiped out but
suddenly stop using their own language
as a way to avoid persecution an example
of this occurred in El Salvador during
an uprising in the 1930s when many
aboriginals abruptly stopped speaking
their native languages as a way to avoid
being identified as aboriginals and
potentially killed two languages that
suddenly died out where Lanka and
caçapava case-studies let's look at a
few languages that have already died and
see if we could figure out how they
ceased to be spoken old Church Slavonic
old Church Slavonic is the first
attested Slavic language which was
spoken and written between the 9th and
11th centuries it was a standardised
variety of Slavic that was understood by
speakers of the various Slavic dialects
of that time which were still quite
to each other those Slovak dialects
which were basically the colloquial form
of the same language gradually developed
into the different Slavic languages of
today because it's still used in some
churches for religious purposes today
it's a liturgical language so it fits in
with the category of bottom to top
language death the newly developing
Slavic languages replaced the old
Slavonic dialects as the languages of
daily life but old Church Slavonic
continued to be used for religious
purposes and for a certain amount of
time for political purposes it's worth
noting that some dead languages never
actually died in both the case of Latin
and of old Slavonic the language never
stopped being spoken it just continued
to evolve into different languages
leaving the codified literary language
behind as a separate dead language that
was no longer spoken the Mandan language
in 2016 a man named Edwin Benson the
last remaining Speaker of the Mandan
language passed away Mandan was a Native
American language of the Siouan language
family which was spoken in the state of
North Dakota the population of Mandan
speakers was nearly wiped out by an
outbreak of smallpox in the 1780s and
again in the 1830s the cohesion of the
remaining population was limited by
government relocation and the
construction of dams which separated
villages from each other while the
influence of English grew the fact that
most of the population was wiped out in
tragic outbreaks of smallpox would place
this in the category of sudden language
death even though some speakers of the
language continued to live on among the
remaining speakers we can also say that
there was an element of gradual language
death as more and more members of that
community began to speak the prestige
language English until one day Mandan
was no longer spoken ghoulish up until
the 6th century seee a Celtic language
called Gaulish was spoken in what's now
France when the Romans conquered the
area they made Latin the official
language of the state and being able to
speak Latin became a way to gain status
and Economic Opportunity for a number of
centuries it was common to be bilingual
and Gaulish vernacular and the prestige
language Latin until Latin finally
replaced Gaulish entirely this is a
clear case of gradual language death as
a population gradually gave up their
traditional language in
favor of the prestige language a Jawa
between 1920 and 1940 the a Jawa
language died out in Nigeria because its
entire community of speakers switched to
Xhosa for economic and practical reasons
the entire community very rapidly
stopped using their traditional language
and it was not passed down to the next
generation this is an example of radical
language death when a language dies
because all of its speakers suddenly
switch to another language in many cases
of radical language death the community
gives up their language for survival in
the face of violence but in this
particular case they gave up the a java
language because it was more beneficial
for their community to speak house'
why should we care about language death
some people think that language death is
a good thing that less language
diversity is a good thing for example
the leaders of some countries want one
language to be dominant and to replace
all of the others because they think
that will promote the unity of their
country on the other hand a language is
part of a culture so when a language
dies part of that culture dies and a
unique way of seeing the world dies with
it for example let's look at the
endangered kala Wael anguish of Bolivia
Calaway ax is used by a sect of medicine
men who learned the language not only to
understand the ritual practice and oral
tradition of their ancestors but also to
understand the thousands upon thousands
of plant names specific to the Cala wile
anguish that explained the medicine all
uses of different plants in the local
region if Calloway ax disappears then
all of that culture and secret knowledge
will disappear with it linguistic
diversity has been on a steady decline
and of the present nearly 7,000
languages on earth nearly half are
endangered and the top 100 most spoken
languages are spoken by 85% of the
world's population some endangered
languages are finding new life through
revitalization efforts which require
that the language first be recorded and
documented then learned by new speakers
and also used by an enthusiastic and
motivated community and having some
political influence wouldn't hurt either
the question of the day in your country
or in your region are there languages
that are in danger of dying or becoming
extinct how would you feel about those
languages disappearing would something
important be lost be sure to follow
Lange focus on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram and once again
thank you to all of my wonderful patreon
supporters especially my top tier
patreon supporters whose names are on
the screen right now very many thanks to
them by the way on the last video about
Toki poni some of you asked why Toki
poni was listed on the page of patrons
that's because the creator of the Toki
Puna language has been a patron since
last summer but preferred not to appear
on the list but upon request I've begun
listing the name of the language instead
thank you for watching and have a nice
day
[Music]
[Music]